.
EWTH HASGRH HORROR, BU
TO TALITH RUSSIA AS RUSSIA CONT.
THE TALKS COULD COME AONTODAY DC
INFI
OUT AS UKRAINI
E INVASION. L T TAL OF
THAN.
CRUI ME SAYS IOSIONSOVERT V, CER
G TO THEIT.TO TWO SENIOR U.
OFFICIRU
EXPECTED RESISTANCE.
LATATES AND
PUT RUSSIAIPPLE THRU REMOVING SO
S.W.T.
SANCTIS SSL
CKTHATCCO PEOPLE
THAT MITHOUT
PRECEDFOF
RUSSIA'S SE. ARE STARTING TO GE
ACCORDING TO THE U.N., THERE
CASUALTIES INCDI
DEATHS SINCE RUSSICHED ITSE GE N
RUN ITR CIESPONDENRE FIGHTING TP
>> Reporte SHAEN ING AND SEEINTR
MORNG,F EXPL
MOSTLY IN THTHE ST 20
IT'S BE
TH
ST WCHA BIBIG , ESSENTLLE
AGREEING TO SEND DELEGATION  E E
DELEGATION TO PRE SOMETIY T NEGS
A OUT OF THI
EARLIER IN THE D, PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY AG
PRINE ONS BUT
AGREEO THEM
IN BELARUS OAR THE
USE
NEEDLESS TO SAY, BEL IS NONEUTRR
FROM T. IN OUT A
STATEMENT ON THEIR FACEBOOK  ZES
CEAGE THATY WOULD
MEET WITHOUTEAE RIVER.ALEXKOE LT
, HELICO
RUSIANTORY
RINGDELEGATION'S T
MEETING AND RETURNNTIALLY , DA
RT OF GUARANTEE OF
LUEN THAT THIS UKRAINIAN
W
RUSSIAN
MEANWHILE, THOUGH, THE
D
FROM , BUT THEY
DEN FINDING
THEMLV ENCOUNTERING
MENTIONED, ACCORDINGU.S. .
T WE'RE SEEI
THE GROU EXPTA HAD
BEEN TA CITY LIKE KYLD
WE F
RTDEPOT, IT  - WESTERN PAROF CI
WAS PR.
TO
ISO SER.BEERY
ANYTHING, TRANSPIRES FROM THESN
A TIMING ON WHEN THE
BEN.
>> CA WE'RE GOING TAL
THAT ALKSHI
UR GUESTS
UPE YOU'RE ON THE GROUND
BEEN DOING SUCH
AMG REPORTING,OUT
TALK ABOUT THE HUMANLE
HAVE WITNE ANDY,CAA A AVE BEEN
RANG THEIR
IAND  N GOO
F TH AT  HOUR?epte I TO THAT
FIRST OF, YOSE
NATURAL HUON
E PE
ESPECI AS THIS WAS BEGNGBOMBAR
HAVE D THIS IN
TITHEY WERE TAKING
AWEITNO SENSE OEN THE  TO GOP A
WHAT'SXTRAORDINARYOU
ME TIME 'R
COURAGE, THE ADI
KNEELIDOWN IN FRONT OF A RUSSIAT
FROM MOVINHEN S  PVET
IEWEAT THEION WHERE THOUSANDANPI
IENDS OWN A BAR IN
KYIVW USING IT
FOOD TGIVE TO UKRAINIAN LI
SHOULD LD ERTHELD SAID TO HER, I
LEAND LEAVD WITH ME, THATNARAGE.
>> IUR.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
NE ORTING, CLARISSA.
CREW SAFE.
N --TODAY THE UNIT HD A RARE
EYE TO H
MDAE N INME O ITED NATIONS
DAM AMAD.
LET WITH THEEWS THAT NSS WILL
NS ON
S  ARE YOU THAT,AND HOW OPTIMIS?
WELL, TGO HASO
KE ANDTHEY H
WE'LOKAT
THOSE DISCUSSIONSW,LEAN IN ON
DIPLOMACY WIHES HOUT THIS AN
HOPE THATIN WOULD EG
PL
AGAIN, TS NEANOTHER
THE UKFI
OT
TABLE.
E POINT OF V
E YOU WER IN UP THA WAS AEFFOR?
I CAN'TO THE NTO S HEADR
USEASEENLES IT THE. DOES S THI I
WANTED T ASOLUTION ANDRONTATIOL
FFORT TO BRING THE
RUSSIANS TO THGOTIATIN NEWNS NO
AND  SAY THE
CER
IN RUSSIAN BAICH
W.UT ERGCT. PAR RUSSIANHEE.T  AT
>> THIS PROCESS COUEWE'RE PUTTIU
THF THXT
TREA CME
NGO
PROCESURPOSE OF E NCTION A REN T